And here's my answer: this is all initialization over here, so we shouldn't touch it.
But from here on, we want to do things twice.
So we're going to put a "for" loop here,
for t in range(T)
and then you have to indent all the stuff below.
I indent all the way to the final statement,
but I only want to print the final distribution.
Let's run it--and surprisingly,
the orientations aren't really that well worked out.
If I go down I find, still fairly random orientations here.
But if I go to 10 steps forward,
which means the robot really moves quite a bit
across its environment,
and I hit the run button--
I actually get orientations that all look alike.
So you can see, they're all about 3.6, 3.8, 3.9, 3.7.
You can see the "y" values are all about the same
and the "x" values are all about the same.
So this is the particle filter working.